Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today, I’m going to explain an American
science fiction drama film called “Equals.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie begins in a futuristic world.
Mankind went through a devastating war a century
earlier.
The war only left two peninsulae suitable
for inhabitants.
One of the peninsulae works under a legislative
body called the collective.
The collective has set extreme rules and laws
to make sure such a war does not emerge again.
The citizens of the peninsula are called the
‘members’, and the collective monitors
and controls all of the member’s actions.
With a futuristic approach to solving the
problem, everyone in the peninsula is made
mentally stable.
All emotions and diseases have been eradicated.
People live an automated life; they do not
talk to each other unless they have to.
The concept of friendship and relationship
is gone, and any show of emotion is considered illegal.
Marriage is non-existent and any form of sexual
activity is contrary to society's rules.
Babies are born strictly through artificial
insemination.
On the other hand, no one knows what is in
the other peninsula.
People assume that primitive human emotions
are allowed there.
Silas is a member of the peninsula.
He too is mentally stabilized and is void
of any emotions.
He works as an illustrator at Atmos.
When Silas walks out of his futuristic home,
we see that everyone around him is in white attire.
Large skyscrapers spread throughout the city,
and everyone seems to be automated.
As per usual, he walks into his workplace,
a voice announces a disease called the Switched-On
Syndrome, more commonly called SOS; it is
a condition in the members of the peninsula,
where their mental stabilization stops working,
and they start to get their emotions back.
It has four stages and is considered fatal
by ‘the collective’.
The members are daily reminded of the effects
of SOS via an announcement.
Nia is Sila’s colleague and a fellow member
of the peninsula.
That day at lunch, the members eat in their
outdoor cafeteria.
While they engage in a conversation about
work, Nia stays especially quiet.
While returning home that night, Silas comes
across two guards restraining a man named David.
A woman who is also restrained screams David’s
name in dismay.
The two are suffering from SOS and have gained
their emotions back.
They are being taken into a facility called
DEN, Defective
Emotional Neuropathy.
DEN was established by ‘the collective’
to hold in the patients suffering from SOS.
While not many people know of what occurs
inside the place, it is rumored that the people
from the 4th stage get killed mercilessly
as the stage is beyond healing.
The display of emotions unsettles Silas.
He then comes back to his apartment and we
get a full view of it.
It doesn’t have any decoration or furniture
and is highly modernized.
To pass his time, Silas plays a futuristic
puzzle game.
The following day, Silas listens to the news,
which reports that David and his partner were
arrested for being engaged in sexual activities.
As Silas and his team work that day, a man
jumps from the top of the building to commit suicide.
The team watches the dead body and talks about
it coldly.
Just then, Silas notices signs of human emotions
in Nia.
Her hands are tightened and she seems nervous.
He notices the oddness but doesn’t think
much of it.
Later, they are in an auditorium watching
a presentation, where Silas cannot stop looking
at Nia.
At night, he eats quickly and seems to be
enjoying his food.
He doesn’t play with puzzles either; he
is beginning to go out of his automated personality.
He dreams of his trying to commit suicide
and wakes up in distress and hits his head.
This is the first time he has ever had a nightmare.
The following day, he goes to the doctor where
he meets a man named Jonas, who is in level
two of SOS.
The doctor checks Silas, and it turns out
that he has level one SOS.
He asks the doctor if he has to go to the
DEN,[sPause time="0.2s" ePause] but the doctor
assures him that cure at level one is easy
and possible.
At lunch, Silas again keeps staring at Nia.
He seems to be observing her facial features.
Silas gets his medication for SOS and takes
it at night, while listening to a voice narrating
the effects and causes of SOS.
The voice adds that people with the last stage
of SOS, stage four, are taken to DEN and are
electrocuted for showing emotions.
The sick will go through a pain-free death
scenario.
The following day at work, Silas cannot concentrate
and is distressed.
He even cries while working and tries to hide
it from his colleagues.
He follows Nia around work at all times.
The next morning, he switches his work with
a colleague to get closer to Nia.
As she explains the work to him, he doesn’t
seem to concentrate and keeps staring at her.
Silas stays late after work and listens to
Nia’s recorded voice on her computer.
He has begun falling in love with her.
The next day, Silas and his team are in a
meeting, when he accidentally drops a mug
of coffee.
He admits that he is suffering from level
one SOS.
The group collectively decides that Silas
should stay as far as possible while working,
so that the others feel more comfortable.
After work, as Nia leaves for her apartment,
Silas follows her.
Nia catches him in the act but Silas in turn
questions her if she has SOS too.
He tells her about him noticing her demure
change when the guy committed suicide that week.
Nia insists she is fine and leaves.
The following day at work, Silas stays as
far as possible from everyone, but doesn’t
stop looking at Nia.
The two act like the conversation yesterday
never happened.
Both of them work late that day.
Nia goes to the bathroom and Silas follows
her.
He gets into her bathroom stall and goes inside.
The two are close when they touch each other
for the first time.
Silas feels Nia’s face in awe.
Nia reveals that she has had SOS for a year
now; she never went to the doctor because
she was afraid of being sent to the DEN. [sPause
time="0.2s" ePause]
She then tells him that their being together
is too risky, so they can’t meet like this again.
The two get up and finally kiss.
It is now the next day, and everyone has left
the office except the two.
Nia again leaves for the restroom and Silas
follows.
The two hold onto each other, but are too
afraid to move on with the relationship.
They kiss again.
From the following day, they start sneaking
into the restroom every day.
They laugh, talk, and kiss.
The two are falling in love.
One day, Atmos’s manager, Leonard, comes
into the restroom while the two are together.
Nia stays hidden while Silas goes out and
talks to him.
As it turns out, someone had reported Silas’s
strange behavior to Leonard.
He warns Silas of the consequences of sneaking
around, and leaves.
The two talk on their way back home, and Silas
tells her that he will look for another job
to not get caught, so the next day, Silas
resigns from his job.
A man named Dominic replaces him as Silas
gets a new job at a nursery.
At night, while picking up medicines, Silas
meets Jonas again.
The two talk for a while and Jonas reveals
that he is a part of a support group with
people who are suffering from SOS.
He offers to help Silas if he needs it.
Soon, Silas visits the support group and meets
its members namely Bess, Peter, Thomas Gil,
Max, and Alice.
There, he finds out that half the patients
brought to DEN commit suicide as the staff
encourages them.
Some even watch them kill themselves.
As opposed to electro restraints, suicide
seems more preferable to everyone.
Silas is shocked.
Later that night, Nia knocks on his door.
He brings her inside and she breaks down crying.
She had missed him too much.
One thing leads to another and the two end
up having sex.
From the following day, the two meet every
night at Silas’s apartment.
Silas has completely stopped taking his medication.
The two are beyond happy with their lifestyle.
That is until one morning, they hear the announcement
that a medication to treat SOS has been made.
The announcer suggests everyone who has been
diagnosed with SOS to take the medicine.
SOS of any level can be treated with it.
Scared that they will not be able to feel
anymore, Silas and Nia go to the support group.
They have decided to run away to the other
peninsula.
Bess tells them that it is not a good idea,
but they have made their decision.
They decide to leave in three days with Jonas’s
help.
However, Nia gets a conception call from ‘the
collective’.
They want her to artificially bear a child.
If the doctor checks her blood results, they
will diagnose her with SOS.
Scared, she tells this to Silas who asks her
to meet him at the clinic after her appointment.
At the clinic, the doctor informs Nia that
she is pregnant.
Silas sees two guards taking her away, but
he cannot do anything.
They take her to DEN. [sPause time="0.2s"
ePause]
Silas frantically asks Jonas for help, who
tells him to go home and wait for a couple
of hours.
Bess, who is also a worker at DEN, frees Nia
and takes her to the rest of the support group.
They make her dress up as fast as she can.
Bess then explains to her that a patient named
Eva had killed herself last night.
Bess has changed her records to Nia’s.
So now Nia can live freely as Eva.
Nia runs away to Silas’s apartment but is
surprised when she doesn’t find him there.
Meanwhile, Silas is at work where it is announced
in the news that Max had reported Bess, Jonas
and Gilead.
So now, all three of them were cured and void
of emotions.
He then runs to DEN’s headquarters and asks
a worker about Nia.
He informs him of her death.
Silas is devastated.
He goes blank and starts having a panic attack.
Nia goes searching for him when he doesn’t
return back to the apartment.
Meanwhile, Silas climbs on top of Atmos’s
building to commit suicide.
As he is about to jump, he changes his decision.
When he gets back to his apartment, he is
greeted by a worried Nia.
She immediately notices the mark on his neck.
Silas has been cured of SOS.
Nia asks him why he did that, to which he
replies that he thought she was dead.
The cure only takes effect in six hours, so
he only has one more hour before his emotions
go away.
Nia is still pregnant, so she asks Silas to
fight the cure.
The two still decide to go through the plan
to run away.
The next morning, Silas remembers that he
loved her but doesn’t feel it anymore.
He tells her to get dressed to go to the train
as they had decided.
In the train, Nia is disappointed as Silas
sits two seats away from her.
Nia reminisces of all the good times with
Silas.
Just then, he sits on the seat beside her
and holds her hand, suggesting that he will
soon recover and gain his emotions back.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on notifications, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thank you for watching.